Welcome students
to Pharmacology.
This is Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
We will begin with
Pharmacodynamics.
This is a two
-part lecture.
This first part is
about the introduction
to the drug receptor
interactions
and the dose-response
relationship.
I am available to
speak to individuals,
to your study groups,
to any groups that
you would like to zoom
on with me or come
to my office for a
pharmacology chat.
This is pharmacology.
These are the two
basic concepts of
pharmacology of all drugs.
Pharmacodynamics
is boiled down to
what the drug does
to the body and how.
And pharmacokinetics
is what the
body does to the
drug and how.
So pharmacodynamics,
we're
talking about
mechanisms of action,
dose response
relationships,
and in pharmacokinetics
we're talking about
how the drugs are
absorbed, administered,
how they distribute
throughout
the body, how they are
metabolized, how
they are excreted.
Metabolism and
excretion is sometimes
lumped into one
word elimination.
This lecture is about
the pharmacodynamics.
Learning Objectives.
This is the answer to the
question, what do
I need to know?
I suggest that you
focus your studies. Be
careful of going down
rabbit holes. levels.
You are being hit
with lots and lots
and lots of material
to take in, so the
idea is to become
efficient as possible
with your studying,
to actually learn
the concepts so
they stick with you.
And they'll be with you
when you take the exam.
And they will very
likely stay with
you after you take
the exam so that
you can apply them
them as you continue
on through your
medical education.
I don't normally go
over the learning
objectives, but
I do want to take
time to do it now so
you get an idea of
the concept of
learning objectives.
So the first one that
I have here is to apply
the physiology of
receptors, effectors, in
In other words, the
molecules that interact
with the receptors to
produce a response or
no response, and the
signaling mechanisms.
You need to be
able to define all
terms, it's the
language of medicine,
the language of
pharmacology.
So define all terms
that are listed in
the notes handout
and give examples of
the specific actions
for therapeutic
effects. Now, I want
to point out that
I have a companion
notes handout
for each and
every lecture.
This is an
optional resource.
I highly suggest
searching the
handout in order
for you to be able
to answer your
practice questions.
So all of the
terms that are
listed in the
handout are also
PowerPoint. point.
Now you need
to be able to
understand the
relationships.
Relate how the
physicochemical
characteristics, which
you'll see are related
to the structural
features of the
drug, the structure,
it's a chemical,
it's some kind
of a molecule.
How these physicochemical
characteristics
determine the drug's
ability to initiate
a cellular effect, the
effector mechanism.
You should be able
to correlate the
concentration of the
drug, which is going
to be determined by
the dose, receptor
occupancy, and the
magnitude, the size,
of the pharmacologic
response by by
comparing dose-dependent
therapeutic and
toxicologic properties,
responses I mean.
Describe the
concepts of intrinsic
activity, affinity,
potency, and
efficacy by comparing
the graded dose
-response curves of
two or more drugs.
And all of these
will come clear as
we go through the
lectures. These
are preparation
materials. The links
are in the CPG,
but they're also on
the next slide.
Everything that's in
the CPG, the class
preparation guide,
is also on these
introductory slides.
ScholarRx bricks
are required by the
school, and my
practice questions,
which are not
graded, are required
by me. Everything
else is optional.
If you like to watch
videos to learn
things by, by all
means watch this video.
If you like to read,
I suggest textbooks
which I'll show you
links on the next page.
You can read my notes
handout. There is
no reason to memorize
the notes handout.
And I have supplied
some guided reading
questions questions
to help you focus on
what's important.
You may use these or
not. It depends on
how you like to study.
If you do choose
to read the guided
reading questions, or
even as you're going
along watching the
PowerPoint or looking
at the printout
of the PowerPoint,
frame questions in
your own mind or
follow the guided
reading questions and
answer them in your
own words first. This
will help you know
if you understand.
And if you can't
answer them in your
own words, then
look at the answers,
think about it, apply
it to what you already
know, and try
answering that again in
your own words. These
are some little learning
techniques that will
help you to remember,
not just memorize,
but to understand.
These are the links I
mentioned, ScholarRx
bricks that are
related to the
pharmacodynamics lectures,
and some optional
resources if you
like. I've put a
textbook down here.
This is the first one,
Katzengevanderol's
Basic and Clinical
Pharmacology. It's
quite easy to read.
Then I have included
a Lippincott
Illustrated Reviews.
This is a review book.
It's a pharmacology
review book and it
is very easy to follow.
It is not loaded
with a lot of
information, just really
the information that
you need to know.
I'm going to spend a
little time talking
about learning
techniques. I will not be
doing this in later
lectures as you move
on. Hopefully you
will understand about
them and be using
them by that time. So
guided reading questions
I already mentioned.
The practice
questions are for your
own assessment of
your learning. If you
can answer my practice
questions, which are
sometimes simple
and sometimes not so
simple, then you can
really know that you
understand the concepts
of pharmacology.
With regard to the
practice questions,
I recommend that
you do a search of
the notes handout.
All the answers are
in the notes handout.
Just search it.
Practicing through case
vignettes will help
you bridge pharmacology
science and
pharmacotherapeutics,
the clinical concepts.
Why are you here?
You want to be able to
understand drugs, to
be able to prescribe
them intelligently and
competently and
confidently. But you need
to be able to understand
the basic concepts.
Write down your own
questions as you
study, as you're
watching the video,
as you're looking
at the PowerPoint
printout, and
you see something
that you wonder
about, write it down.
And that way you're
already thinking
about it, and when
the answer comes
up, you'll be ready
to receive it.
And some more tips.
identify and define
key ideas and
concepts, rephrase main
ideas in your own words,
convert main points
to questions. When
you write a question,
you really have
to think about it,
and thinking about it
helps you remember.
Relate the ideas to
what you already know.
Space your practice,
mix up multiple subjects,
you can't do this
really until you're a
lot more comfortable
with the information.
And of course, use memory
devices, mnemonics
to help you remember.
This is an example
of a concept map or
mind map, some people
call it. You can see
how all of the different
features, at least
in this lecture that
we're going to be
talking about, are
related to each other.
You can use concept
maps if you're
comfortable with
them, just you can
draw them out with
your own hand.
There are also
computer models for
making concept
maps. Concept maps
can sometimes be
time consuming,
but some students
find them very
helpful. Now I start
the lectures with
information that you
really need to know,
key concepts that
you need to know.
So, these are the
focus points for you.
I don't go over them.
This is for you.
If you wish to
use them, I highly
recommend that you
use it. It gives you
a good overview of
what the lecture
is about and it puts
it into context.
I did mention that
you need to be
able to understand
terms, define the
terms. This is
the language of
pharmacology, the
language of medicine.
So I've listed terms that
you should be
able to know.
And when you can,
this is true, this is
memorization, but when
you have them under
your belt, as it
were, you will be able
to quickly understand
what I am talking
about, what others are
talking about, what
your tendings are
talking about, and this
is more of what you
need to know. I will
not be reading these
slides to you. You
can read them perfectly
well on your own.
So let us begin.
The physicochemical
characteristics of
a drug determine
its ability to move
through the body and
initiate a cellular
effect. That is the
whole point of a drug.
That's how
pharmaceutical companies,
drug development
companies develop drugs.
There are pharmacokinetic
properties and
pharmacodynamic
properties and these
are related to the
structural features.
So what are we
talking about with the
structural features?
factors, the size of
the molecule, the
shape of the molecule.
Does it have
chirality? Does it not?
What is the
electrical charge? Is
it lipid soluble?
All of these features
will determine
whether or not it
actually gets to
the site of action.
And once it's
there, will it fit
its particular
target, its receptor?
So let's look at
the pharmacokinetic
properties first. The
structural features determine
the drug's ability
to be absorbed. Will
it be absorbed from
the GI tract? If not,
then it's going to
have to be injected.
Will it distribute
to the site of
action? In other
words, will it pass
through the
physiologic membranes,
the lipid bilayers
of the gut?
What will happen to it
when it's in the liver?
Will it get out
into the systemic
circulation and
once there, will it
actually get to its
target? If the target
is in the brain and
the drug does not
cross the blood
-brain barrier, then
it's not going to
get to its target.
What will be the
extent of its
metabolism as it
passes through
the liver and
other organs?
How will it be
excreted? Will it be
excreted as metabolites
that are inactive?
Will it be excreted
as active drug?
All of these are
related to the
structural features
of the molecule.
Now let's take
a look at the
pharmacodynamic
properties. You see I
have written
here on the side,
structure, activity,
relationship.
That's the whole point.
It needs to have
a structure that's
going to be able to
fit into its target.
So with
some, in fact many, of
the drugs we'll talk
about, I will ask
you to understand how
the structure is
related to its activity.
I don't ask you
to be able to draw
structures, just understand
the relationship.
So the structural
features will
determine the
receptor specificity.
Will this drug bind to
one type of receptor
or is it not very
specific and it will bind
to a variety of different
types of receptors,
which is really not
ideal for a drug.
What is the affinity
for the receptor?
Does it bind
tightly? Does it
bind weakly, somewhere
in the middle?
Does the drug
molecule activate
the effect that a normal
endogenous natural
drug ligand, I mean
not drug, endogenous
ligand would produce?
An endogenous
ligand binds to its
receptor and produces some
activity, whatever
that is specific for
the receptor type and
for the cell type,
well will the drug be
able to produce the
same response or some
portion of a response?
That's called
intrinsic activity.
Here's an example of
structure activity
relationship. You
see on the right hand
side on the upper
structure a very simple
molecule and that is
called epinephrine.
Epinephrine has
another name. It's
called adrenaline
and that is
a natural hormone
in our bodies.
Looking at the
structure below, you see
they look very, very
similar. The only
difference is that
phenylephrine is missing
this hydroxyl group
and that gives it
very similar
properties, but slightly
different properties.
And that's an example
of the structure
-activity relationship.
Now we most often look
at these structures
flat like this,
two-dimensionally,
but they have a
three-dimensional
shape in space. And it is
that three
-dimensional shape
that determines its
biologic
activity. acidity.
We talk about
molecular mechanisms of
drug action. I
mentioned before that an
endogenous or natural
ligand binds to
its receptor and
produces some response.
That's a molecular
mechanism. Does the drug
do the same thing?
That's the molecular
mechanism of the drug.
whatever the drug causes
that's its molecular
mechanism. So the
interaction of a drug with
its target brings about
a change in biologic
function because the
drug is binding to
its target and causing
something to happen as
a result of the binding
and that produces the
pharmacologic effect.
Now there are a couple
of pharmacologic
effects that we're going
to be talking about.
in this lecture.
So it can activate
the biochemical and
physiologic changes
that are characteristic
of the receptor.
It's all about the
receptor. The drug is
causing the receptor to
do whatever the
receptor normally does.
Or a drug can block
the receptor so that
the natural ligand
is not able to access
and therefore there
will be no response.
So it's a blocker,
an inhibitor.
So it can activate or
inhibit, bottom line.
Now talking about
the duration of
action from a
pharmacodynamic perspective,
we're also going
to be talking
about it from a
pharmacokinetic
perspective when we
get to that point.
From a pharmacodynamic
perspective,
the drug's action
may persist,
the duration of action,
until the drug
dissociates, moves away
from the receptor,
and that will
automatically stop the
effect. And this happens
when drug is
discontinued. It will
leave the receptor,
there are no other
drug molecules around
to activate the
receptor and the
effect is terminated.
The drug can activate
second messengers and
signal transduction.
So the drug may have
residence on the receptor
for only a very brief
period of time, but
it has activated
intracellular responses
and therefore the duration
of action will be
much longer than one
would expect considering
the brief residence
on the receptor. receptor.
The drug receptor
complex is destroyed
and new receptors or
enzymes have been
synthesized. So here I want
to say that when we
talk pharmacology ease,
receptors is a big
word. It can be enzymes,
it can be receptors
on the cell surface,
inside, it can
be nucleic acid, it's
whatever the drug
target is. So sometimes
the terminology
kind of gets
confused. But please
understand that
receptors might mean any
of those things. It
is the drug target.
Now going back to
this point here,
let's say a drug
binds with very, very,
very high affinity
to the receptor.
It just does not
dissociate. And
the cell recognizes
that its receptor
that has the drug
bound is useless.
So it will internalize
the receptor.
Let's say this
is the receptor.
This is a very
poor picture.
Here's the drug on here.
And it will get
internalized and it will
go into the lysosome
and be degraded.
And thus, new enzyme
or new receptors have
to be synthesized by
that cell. And that can
take some time. So
the duration of action
is extended because
we are waiting
for the cell to replace
that drug receptor
complex that has
been destroyed.
Receptor effector
systems incorporate
desensitization
mechanisms for preventing
excessive activation
when agonist molecules
continue to be present
for long periods.
I want to say right
here, I'm not going
to explain it now,
we will get to that.
So let's take a look
at some quantitative
aspects, dose
response curves.
When you hear
pharmacodynamics
you're going
to be thinking
about the
quantitative aspects
as well as
mechanism of action.
What we have here is
a receptor occupancy
theory that assumes
that the portion of
occupied receptors is
related to the effect.
How many receptors
are occupied, that's
going to be related
to the size of the
effect. And this is
based in the law of
mass action. So what
we have here is the
relationship between
the drug concentration
and the pharmacologic
response.
So drug receptor,
drug receptor complex,
response.
This k plus 1, with
the arrow pointing in
this direction, this
is the association
constant. This is the
rate of association
of the drug and the
receptor to form the
complex. complex. This
one with the minus
one is the rate of
dissociation. The
rate at which the
drug receptor complex
dissociates into the
drug and the receptor.
So,
the number of
receptors that's the
concentration of
receptors occupied by the
drug depends on how
many drug molecules
are there. The
concentration of drug.
The drug receptor
association rate.
And the drug receptor
dissociation rate.
So drug association,
drug receptor
complex, effect.
Equilibrium. So,
when the association,
the rate of association
equals the rate of
dissociation, we
have the equilibrium
dissociation constant,
KD, and we're going to be
talking about this
for the next several
slides. the equilibrium
dissociation constant.
That represents the
drug concentration
required to saturate 50
% of the receptors. Why?
Because we have
dissociation, rate of
association, rate of
dissociation at equilibrium.
So there are some
complex drug receptor
complexes and drug and
receptor uncomplexed.
KAD represents the
drug concentration
required to
saturate 50% of the
receptors. Now the
affinity constant
is the inverse,
it's a reciprocal.
The greater the
affinity the smaller
the equilibrium
dissociation constant.
Alternatively,
the lower the
affinity the greater
the equilibrium
dissociation constant.
Let's see if
we can clarify
this as we go along.
Here we have graded
dose response
curves. So on the x axis,
we have the
concentration of drug A.
And here we have
something called
the EC50, the
concentration of drug
that produces is
50% of maximal
response. So E
stands for effect.
C obviously
concentration.
Now here we have, it's
really hard to see
it here. So by plotting
the log concentration
of the drug, we get
a sigmoid curve.
And now we can see
the concentration at
which 50% of the
concentration of drug
that produces 50% of
the maximal response.
Maximal response
on the y axis,
concentration of
drug on the x axis.
Okay, now we're going
to be using this
concept together
with equilibrium
dissociation constant
and receptor occupancy.
And here it is.
The concentration
effect and
the receptor
binding curves.
On the left hand
side we see the drug
concentration effect
relationship. So here's
the concentration of
drug again, here's the
effect of drug. We saw
that on the previous
slide. side, and
this is obviously not
log concentration,
but it's stretched out
for us so we can see
it, and here's our
concentration at which
50% response occurs.
On the right hand
side, oh, let me just
point out this is
maximal effect here.
This is 50% of effect,
this is maximal effect.
Here we have drug
concentration again.
Now we have the
concentration of
receptors that are
bound by the drug.
The equilibrium
dissociation constant, the
concentration at which
50% of the receptors
are bound. And here
we have the maximal
number of receptors
in the receptor pool.
It's easy to see by
looking at these two
curves that they appear
to be superimposable,
illustrating
the relationship
between the dose
-response and the
dose-receptor
occupancy curves.
In this model, the
maximal effect occurs
when the maximal number
of receptors in the
receptor pool are
occupied by the drug.
This is not always
the case, but
we're starting
with a simple idea
and we will build
on it as we go.
The graded dose-receptor
relationship and
the graded dose-response
relationship assume
that the magnitude
of the response,
how large is the
response of the
drug, is proportional
to the concentration
of drug at the
effector site.
Now what determines
the concentration
of drug at the effector
site? The dose.
The dose determines
the concentration of
drug in the biologic
fluid and what we're
talking about almost
always is plasma, blood,
serum, you're going to
see all these terms.
Pharmacokinetic concepts.
And this will determine,
concentration in
the blood, will determine
the concentration
of drug at the effector
site because once
the drug gets to the
systemic circulation,
it will be
distributed to the
effector site,
depending of course on
its physicochemical
properties.
Now if there are only
a few molecules of
drug at the effector
site, then there
will be a smaller
effect than if there are
a gazillion, well
obviously not a gazillion,
but lots and lots
and lots of drug
molecules at the
effector site. Now why?
Because remember
about dissociation
association, association,
dissociation,
association, dissociation.
Nearly all drugs will
reversibly bind to
its target. So that
means it will associate
and the rate of
association will depend
on its structural
characteristics and it
will dissociate. So,
once it dissociates,
then another drug
molecule can occupy the
receptor site. And
when it dissociates,
another drug molecule
occupies, and it
dissociates, another
drug molecule occupies.
So if there are lots
of drug molecules
in the vicinity of
the target, there are
plenty of drug
molecules to occupy the
receptor when the
one that's there
dissociates. Now, if
there are only a few,
there may not be
a drug molecule
ready to jump
onto that site.
There's a very
important point to
understand here
with receptors and
drug molecules
and all of that.
It's a probability
that the drug
molecule will bump
into the receptor
and have enough
affinity to bind
to it. It's all
about probability.
So if there are lots
of drug molecules,
the probability
of another
drug molecule binding
is very great.
If there are only a
few drug molecules
in the vicinity, then the
probability is less.
And that's really
all there is to
this whole concept.
Drug dose determines
the concentration in
blood. blood, the drug
distributes to the
effector site, so the
concentration in the
blood determines
the concentration at
the site of action,
and how many molecules
are at the site of
action will determine
the magnitude of the
pharmacologic effect.
So let's talk some
more terms here.
Intrinsic activity,
the ability of a drug
bound to its receptor
to activate downstream
effector mechanisms.
mechanisms. So a drug
that is capable of
activating the receptor
and the receptor
activating its downstream
effector mechanisms
has intrinsic activity.
And we talk about
intrinsic activity in
terms of does it
produce the full effect?
Then yes, then it has
high intrinsic activity.
Does it produce a
partial level of
effect? This is called
a partial agonist.
It does have
intrinsic activity,
but not as much as
the full agonist.
Efficacy, the
quantitative ability of a
drug to elicit a
physiologic response when it
interacts with a
receptor, and of course
this is related to the
intrinsic activity.
Now what I want to
point out here is the
pure pharmacology meaning
of efficacy compared
to the everyday usage
of efficacy. So,
this definition
here is the
pure pharmacology
definition.
Agonists have efficacy,
inhibitors do not
have efficacy.
But in everyday
language, if a drug
is effective, it
means it has efficacy,
it's efficacious.
So, please try
and separate the
pharmacology pure
definition and the
everyday meaning.
And believe me, you're
going to be using
efficacy, efficacious
as meaning effective,
and you'll be
using it for
inhibitors, agonists,
whatever drug.
Potency.
Potency is the
concentration of
drug required to
produce an effect.
And that's going
to be related to
the drug's affinity
for its target. So
we're talking about
the concentration
necessary to
produce the effect.
So we will
illustrate these
in the upcoming
slides. sides.
These two charts
demonstrate relative
efficacy and relative
potency. So the upper
chart is efficacy. We
see drug A and drug B
binding to the same
receptor and therefore
for the function is
the same and they have
intrinsic activity.
But drug A is a full
agonist. It produces
the maximal effect
that that receptor is
capable of producing.
Drug B produces is
some lower effect.
It has partial
activity. It is
called a partial
agonist. So they both
produce an effect.
They both bind to
the same receptor
so it's the same
action but it's a
different magnitude.
Full efficacy or full
effect compared
to partial effect.
Now, looking at
the lower two
curves, we have
drug C and drug D.
Drug C will produce 50%
of the response at
this concentration.
Whatever this is,
let's say it's
one. Let's say
it's one milligram.
Drug D will produce
the same full effect,
but it takes more
drug. It takes a
higher dose. So let's
say this is 100 mg.
The EC50 is 100 mg
to produce 50% of the
response for drug
D and drug C, 1 mg
will produce 50% of
the response. They
both produce the same
Efficacy is just a
matter of how much
drug is needed at the
receptor site to
produce that effect.
So remember potency is
related to affinity.
So a drug that requires
a lower concentration,
I didn't do a very
good circle there,
is going to need fewer
molecules because
it has higher
affinity. It stays
attached to the
receptor, it occupies the
receptor, for a longer
duration of time.
Its rate of
association and
its rate of,
let me back up.
The rate of dissociation
of the drug with
the higher affinity
is much longer. It
takes longer for it
to dissociate because
it has a high affinity
for the receptor.
Drug D, on the
other hand,
has a lower
affinity, so it will
dissociate much
more rapidly.
And it requires
more molecules
to be there
to jump on the
receptor once drug
D dissociates.
So that's potency.
In this example we
see dose response
curves of different
shapes and
this can have a
clinical impact.
Drug B is a partial
agonist. That's
easy to see here.
It does not produce
maximal efficacy
compared to A, C, and D,
which do produce
the maximal effect.
However,
drug B is the most
potent of these four.
The EC50 is at this
point furthest to the
left, meaning that
fewer molecules are
needed to produce the
maximal effect that drug
B is capable of. it's
a partial agonist.
Now drug A, C, and D
have EC50s approximately
in the same location
because they have
the same maximal
efficacy but A is more
potent than C which
is more potent than D.
Now I'd like to draw
your attention to
the shape of D. It
has a much steeper
slope than the other
drugs on this figure.
Now, what does that mean?
Let's say that the
majority of patients
achieve an effect
somewhere in this
range, and let's say
that drug D actually
has the potential
for serious toxicity.
The dose to achieve
the maximal effect is
fairly close to the
dose that is required
to achieve that will
cause the toxicity.
Let's say it's
an anesthetic and
let's say the
toxicity is coma.
It's very easy to
overshoot from the
therapeutic effect to
the toxic effect and it's
so important to understand
individual patients
risk factors for
optimization of therapy
in the individual
patient. So that's the
meaning of the steep
dose response curve.
Moving now to
spare receptors.
This is another concept.
I had said in a very
simple example that
the effect, let me
back up a little
bit, the maximal
effect is related to
the maximal occupancy
of receptors in the
receptor pool, and
I had said that's
not always true. And
here's an example.
Receptors are said to
be spare for a given
pharmacologic response
if it is possible
to elicit a maximal
biologic response
at a concentration
of agonists that does
not result in
occupancy of the full
complement of available
receptors. So spare,
Here, I gave you a
way to think about
spare, it's a
reserve supply like
a spare tire or
spare cash extra.
And we have two
curves here.
Here's our EC50,
so this is the
concentration at
which, that will
produce 50% of the
maximal response.
And here's our maximal
effect. extract.
This is the
concentration at which
50% of the
receptors are bound
with this being
the maximum number
of receptors in
the receptor pool.
The EC50 is at
one unit of drug
concentration
concentration,
and the KD equilibrium
dissociation constant
is at 10 units of
drug concentration.
So 10 times the
concentration
for, let's say,
EC50 is 1 tenth of
the concentration of
drug needed to produce
the response. So,
all of these extra
receptors, all
of this concentration
in here is
extra receptors
that are not bound,
but maximal effect
still occurs.
Spare receptors are
said to exist if
the maximal response
is obtained at
less than 100%
occupation of the
receptors. That's
all there is to it.
Only a fraction of total
receptors are needed
to elicit a maximal
response, thus the
remaining receptors
that are not bound by
agonists are referred
to as spare receptors.
So how can the
researcher determine if
a drug is producing
the maximal effect
at a lower
concentration than the
number of receptors
that are available.
Well, it can be
done experimentally.
So imagine that the
researcher is injecting
an irreversible inhibitor
into the experimental
animal. So an
irreversible inhibitor
is going to bind to the
receptors and prevent
the agonist from
binding, it's inhibiting,
and it's irreversible
so it stays there.
It does not dissociate.
Now let us say that
a concentration of
agonist is injected,
this is the starting
point, and this is the
effect. So here is the
concentration, the
EC50, at which 50% of
maximal occurs with
the dose of agonist.
Now the researcher will
inject the inhibitor.
Now the researcher
needs to inject more
agonist in order to
achieve an effect.
The full effect is
still achieved but
at a higher
concentration of agonist.
So now the researcher
injects more inhibitor.
And now it takes more,
a higher concentration
of agonist to
produce the effect
and it is a maximal
effect. So from here
to here there are
spare receptors. How
do we know? Well Well
first of all because
it's an irreversible
inhibitor so the
agonist is not
going to bind to the
receptors that the
inhibitor is bound to.
So there are still
some spare receptors
around in order
for the agonist to
bind to and produce
a maximal effect.
Now the researcher
introduces
more inhibitor.
inhibitor.
And then more agonists,
ah, but the receptors
are more and more bound
by that inhibitor.
So they're getting
closer and closer and
closer to maximal
binding by the inhibitor.
So we only get the
partial effect.
And again,
more receptors are
bound, a partial effect,
and if it were to
keep going, eventually
there would be no
effect by the agonist
because all of the
receptors are bound.
So in conclusion,
we're going to
look at some terms.
I'd like you to match the
terms to the
descriptions.
So I invite you to
pause your computer
and see if you can
come up with the
answers. All of the
terms are on the bottom
and match them to
their definitions.
Alright, so you've
turned your computer
back on and let's see
what the answers are.
Actions of the
body on the
drug, pharmacokinetics.
The body is acting
on the drug to
cause it to be
absorbed, distributed,
metabolized,
and excreted.
What are the actions of
the drug on the body?
Pharmacodynamics,
the drug is
causing some kind
of an effect or
blocking some
kind of an effect.
The branch of
science that deals
with the undesirable
effects of
chemicals on the
living system.
Toxicity, toxicology.
The development
of drugs based on
knowledge of the
three-dimensional
structure of the
receptor side. So
this is the drug
development side.
And that's called
rational drug design. And
it's actually computer
-based. The drug
development company runs
a bunch of structures
through the computer
looking for a hit.
The relation of
the individual's
genetic makeup to his or
her response to
specific drugs.
Let's see if you
can figure this
out just from
the description.
Well, of course, it must
be pharmacogenomics,
it has genetics right
there in the name.
The science of
substances used to
prevent, diagnose,
and treat disease.
Prevent, diagnose, and
treat disease, well
that's medicine. medicine,
medical pharmacology,
the specific molecule
in the biologic
system that plays a
regulatory role, the
receptor, and of course
the last one is the drug,
a substance introduced
to the body that
brings about a change
in biologic function
through its interactions
with body components.
This is a preview
for the next
lecture and also
looking back at a couple
of things that
we talked about.
So I invite you to
pause your computer and
see if you can come
up with the matches.
So now you're back.
A drug that binds
to and activates
a receptor but
does not evoke a
maximal response,
no No matter how
high the
concentration of drug.
A partial agonist.
A drug that binds a
receptor, competes with,
and prevents binding
by other molecules.
That's an antagonist.
The relative
ability of a drug
receptor complex
to produce the
maximal functional
response.
Intrinsic Efficacy
A drug that has
a much stronger
affinity for the
inactive shape of
of the receptor than
for the active
conformation state,
and stabilizes a
large fraction of
the inactivated
conformation drug
pool, reducing
constitutive activity.
Now if you didn't get
this, I don't blame
you, we'll talk about
it in the next lecture.
This is called an
inverse agonist. In the
absence of any
agonist, some of the
receptor pool must exist
in the activated form
some of the time and
may produce the same
physiologic effect
as an agonist induced
activity. And this is
called constitutive
activity, or as
they say in certain
parts of the country
constitutive activity.
A drug that binds
to and activates the
receptor in some fashion,
which directly or
indirectly directly
brings about the effect.
An agonist.
A drug that directly
activates a receptor
by binding to a
receptor site different
or distinct from
the primary site. So
that's going to be an
allosteric activator.
And finally, a drug
that binds a receptor
at a site distinct
from the primary site
inhibits the action
of the agonist, and
is not overcome by
increasing the dose of
the agonist, is an
allosteric inhibitor.
So in summary,
pharmacodynamics is
the study of the
biochemical, cellular,
and physiologic
effects of drugs
and their mechanisms
of action, what
the drug does to
the body, and how.
Pharmacokinetics
is the study
of the movement
and fate of
drugs in the
body, absorption,
metabolism, excretion,
what the body
does to the drug,
and how it does it.
Knowledge of
biochemical, cellular,
physiologic, and
pathologic processes is
essential for
understanding pharmacology,
pharmacodynamics,
pharmacokinetics.
Knowledge of
pharmacology is essential
for the safe and
effective use
of drugs. That's
the whole point,
optimizing drug therapy
in the individual
patient.
And I put this
little scheme
here, this little
mind map, to
help you visualize
the concepts.
The physical chemical
characteristics
of a drug determines
its ability to
move through the
body and initiate a
cellular effect.
the physicochemical
characteristics of
a drug that predict
its movement,
predict its movement.
And availability at
sites of action are
its molecular size,
shape, chirality,
degree of ionization,
relative lipid solubility
of its ionized and
non-ionized forms,
and the relative
lipid solubility if it
doesn't have any
ionization. The structure
activity relationship
is the relationship
between the chemical
or 3D structure
of a molecule and the
biologic activity.
The interaction
of a drug with its
receptor is the
fundamental event that
initiates the
action of the drug.
And I've given you
some pictures here of
different types of
receptors and actions.
Drugs interact with
receptors to produce
a change in the state,
the confirmation,
of the receptor which
transduces a
physiologic effect.
The molecular
action with the
receptor can be
modeled mathematically
and obeys the law
of mass action.
The binding of a
drug and receptor
determines the
quantitative relationship
between the dose
and the effect.
Mutual affinity of
drug and receptor
determines the
quantitative
relationship between
dose and effect.
Traditional receptor
occupancy theory
rests on the
assumption that the
proportion of occupied
receptors is related
to the effect of
the drug. For full
agonists, 100%
occupancy produces the
maximal effect, a
linear relationship.
For some receptors, a
biologic response may
be achieved before full
receptor occupancy.
The fraction
of unoccupied
receptors is called
spare receptors.
And here are the
answers to the matching.
My references and
that concludes
this lecture and
you're invited to
please fill out
the feedback form.
Welcome students
to the second part
of our pharmacodynamics
lectures.
In this lecture,
we will talk about
quantifying agonism
and antagonism,
various models,
receptor dynamics,
and pharmacodynamic
variability in a
population. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
I extend an
invitation for a
pharmacology chat.
If you would like
groups or individuals,
all welcome.
Just email me and we'll
set up an appointment
that's convenient for
both or all of us.
Here are the learning
objectives. Just to
remind you, this is
the answer to the
question, what do I need
to know? now, so that
you can focus your
studies and try and
avoid going down rabbit
holes. As interesting
as they are, they can
take up your time.
Compare and contrast
the actions and effects
of agonists and
antagonists as illustrated
by specific concentration
effect curves.
We talked about
those dose-response
relationships concentration
effect curves in
the part one lecture
and now we're going
to apply it to agonists
and antagonists.
We're going to talk
about them in the context
of the classical
receptor occupancy model
and the two-state
receptor occupancy model.
We're going to talk
about competitive
antagonists, non
-competitive antagonists,
negative and
positive allosteric
modulators, and
spare receptors as
demonstrated in
experimental sample models.
We're going to relate
the drug action,
receptor occupancy,
receptor response,
and receptor
regulation based on
concentration effect
curves and receptor
binding of agonists
and antagonists.
And finally,
we will explain the
pharmacodynamic variabilities
in a population
and calculate the
therapeutic index when
given the quantal dose
response curves. These
are the things that
you should be able to
do after you've become
familiar with the
concepts in this lecture.
And here are the
preparation materials in
the CPG and also on
these slides. Scholar
Rx Bricks, Practice
questions are required.
All the rest is at
your own choice.
Whatever works for
you. You will have
to acquire the
knowledge, so do that
in the way that
works best for you.
Here are our links
to textbooks and
our receptor
occupancy model. These
are what you need
to learn about.
I'm not going to
read these slides.
You can read them
yourself perfectly well.
Classical receptor
occupancy model.
Other mechanisms of drug
antagonism.
Receptor dynamics.
You'll hear
about receptor
desensitization,
downregulation, tachyphylaxis,
disease, receptor
resensitization,
supersensitivity,
and pharmacodynamic
variability in
a population.
You can think about
animal experimentation,
you can think about
clinical trials.
So let us begin with
our receptor occupancy
models of agonists
and antagonists.
The two that
we'll talk about,
which are two
basics and as you
read about more
going through
your practice
life, your lifelong
learning, you'll
see others but
you can build on
these two models.
They propose explanations
of the activity
of drugs at receptors.
And these are
founded in abundant
experimentation.
So the two-state
receptor occupancy model,
I'm going to mention
that one first,
postulates
that the receptor assumes
two conformational
states, active and
inactive, in the
absence of a ligand.
So, it can be either
in an active state
or an inactive state.
We're talking about an
entire pool of receptors.
So this is called
the receptor pool.
And some of the receptors
in that pool are
in a conformational
state that's active and
it's going to produce
some basal activity.
Many receptors, I should
say many cells, need
to have some sort of
constitutive activity
in order for
us to function
as human beings,
as organisms.
And some of them
are going to
be in an inactive
conformation.
The receptor can
activate downstream
mechanisms that produce
a small observable
effect even in the
absence of a ligand
and it has constitutive,
other people
say constitutive,
or basal activity.
So that's what
we mean with the
two-state receptor
occupancy model.
There is a total
receptor pool.
Some of the
receptors are in an
active form
producing some basal
amount of activity
and and the others
are in an inactive
conformation.
Now the classical
receptor occupancy
model, which actually
did come first,
postulates that
receptors in a
receptor pool
are quiet unless
they are activated
by a ligand.
That ligand is usually
some natural molecule,
an endogenous molecule,
let's say epinephrine.
I used that as an
example before. 4.
Agonists bind to
receptors and stimulate
the signal transduction
pathways. Agonists
have affinity and
intrinsic activity.
5. Antagonists bind
to receptors and
inhibit or block the
biologic responses
by interfering
with the agonist's
ability to activate
the receptor. here.
Antagonists have
affinity, they will
bind, and the receptor
will bind to them,
but they have zero
intrinsic activity.
They are not causing
the receptor to
activate its downstream
effector mechanism.
And at the same
time, they block
the agonist from
occupying the
site, inhibitors
or blockers.
So let's take a look
at curves in the two
-state model of drug
receptor interaction.
The hypothetical
receptor is able to
assume two conformations,
I explained
that before. So,
on this figure,
we have our active
confirmation or
inactive confirmation.
And here we have our
drug coming in, and
the drug can bind to the
inactive confirmation
and hold it there,
or drug can bind to
the active confirmation
and hold it there.
So, let's take a look
now at these curves.
Talking about a drug.
So a drug that is a
full agonist, you can
see it's producing the
maximal effect, Emax.
The drug will bind to
the receptor in the
active conformation.
It has affinity for
the receptor in the
active conformation.
That's the affinity
that it has.
So it will shift
almost all of
the receptors
in the pool to
the active plus
drug complex,
activating the receptor
-effector systems
to the maximal
effect. Now let's
take a look at the
second curve down.
Here we have a drug
that will bind to
the active
conformation of the
receptor, but it will
also bind to a certain
extent the inactive
conformation.
So partial agonists
have a slightly
greater affinity for
the active conformation
than for the inactive
conformation. And
what is the effect
that we would see?
They do not
stabilize the active
conformation as much as
the full agonists do.
Therefore, a
significant fraction
of the receptors
is in the
inactive drug
complex form.
As a result, there
is some effect, but
it's not the full
effect. It's not
maximal efficacy,
it's a partial effect.
Therefore a partial
agonist produces
only the partial
effect. Now I'd
like, well I'll
point that out later.
Now a neutral antagonist,
here we have our
baseline constitutive
activity, a neutral
antagonist will
have equal affinity
for both the
active confirmation
and the inactive
confirmation.
And what it will
appear is that the
drug has no
effect. So if this
particular drug that
has the equal affinity
is injected into
an animal model
and we're looking
to see what happens,
it looks like
nothing changes.
Whatever
constitutive activity
was going on
continues to go on.
No change.
So it looks
like nothing is
happening. But
the drug is bound.
It's an antagonist
and it's bound to the
receptors and it will
prevent the agonist,
the full agonist or
the partial agonist
from binding. So it
is still inhibiting.
Now the inverse
agonist, I know
this is kind of
a confusing term,
the inverse agonist
will bind to the
inactive conformation
with much higher
affinity than it binds to
the active conformation
and therefore the
inverse agonist
will stabilize the
large fraction of the
receptors in the
inactive conformation.
So what do we see? What
does the researcher
see when the animal
is injected with
a drug that is an
inverse agonist? It will
show that there
is a decrease in
constitutive activity.
The effect decreases,
resulting in the effects
opposite from the
agonist. So it looks
like an inhibitor.
The observable
effect is that of
an inhibitor.
Nothing is happening.
Now the classical
receptor occupancy model,
this is how we talk
about mainly the
classification of
antagonist. So I want you to
just put this whole
two receptor occupancy
model, two receptor
confirmation occupancy
model aside for a moment.
Now you're thinking
about it in a completely
different way.
Competitive antagonists
compete for the
same binding site as
the agonist. So, that's
called the active
site. The agonist binds
to the active site,
produces an effect.
A competitive
antagonist will also
bind to the active
site, but it
will produce no
effect, and it will
prevent the agonist
from binding.
Pretty simple.
It's competitive,
so it associates,
dissociates,
associates, dissociates.
Now, a noncompetitive
antagonist will reduce
the magnitude of
the maximal response
that can be achieved by
any amount of agonist
without having an
effect. In other words,
it's an inhibitor, it
will block the effect
of the agonist but in
a different way than
the noncompetitive
antagonist does. So, we're
going to get into
more detail with that.
I want to draw
your attention to
this figure that
shows these various
actual mechanisms
of antagonism.
Receptor antagonists,
in other words,
they are antagonists
at the receptor.
And we also have non
-receptor antagonists,
they're antagonists
by a non-receptor
mechanism. them,
I'm not going to
go into them right
now, I will later.
So the antagonist
binds to the
active site,
it can bind by
far and away,
the most common
is reversible binding,
association, dissociation,
association,
dissociation, that's a
competitive antagonist.
Now, there are a few
that will bind
irreversibly to the active
site, and because it's
occupying that site
irreversibly, the
agonist cannot get to it.
And then there's the
allosteric binding,
which means to a
neighboring site, it's not
the active site, and
it will cause, it will
bind and cause a
conformational change such
that But the agonist
is unable to bind with
its usual affinity to
the active site and
therefore does not
activate the receptor.
Now these two can
be reversible and
irreversible,
and these are
noncompetitive
allosteric antagonists.
So we have curves
to demonstrate what
we're talking
about. Let's start
with the competitive
antagonist, which
is illustrated in
the top figure.
Competitive here.
This is the
active site here.
And you can see
they both have
affinity for
the active site.
Now how do we demonstrate
this experimentally?
With our agonist
curves. So here's
the starting point,
right here, the
control they call
it. So that's the
agonist is injected
and we see some
response, here's our
maximal response,
that occurs at
this concentration.
Now, if a competitive
antagonist is
injected into this
animal, and then,
this is a certain
concentration and then
the agonist is injected
again, now at a
higher concentration,
the agonist will be
able to out-compete
the antagonist at the
receptor site and
again produce the
maximal effect, but we
see it takes a greater
concentration of
agonist to achieve
that. And more competitive
antagonist, again
achievable with a
greater concentration
of the agonist, etc.,
on down the line.
This is an
experimental situation
to demonstrate
that a competitive
antagonist can
be outcompeted
if the concentration of
agonist is high enough.
Now an irreversible
active site
antagonist is
indicated here.
It binds to the active
site, the agonist
cannot bind, and with
increasing concentrations
of irreversible
antagonist, the
effect is totally
reduced, agonist effect.
Now here we have a
positive allosteric
modulator. Now this
is not an inhibitor.
It's actually
activating the receptor.
So what's happening
here? receptor.
This is our
control again.
This would be
the regular Emax.
A drug that binds to
an allosteric site,
so it's a neighboring
site and it's going
to cause a conformational
change in the
receptor active site
such that it actually
enhances the affinity
of the agonist,
whether that's a
natural receptor agonist
or a drug, so that
it produces an effect
that's above the usual
maximal effect. So
this is a positive
allosteric modulator.
It's producing a
positive effect on the
receptor's action. A
negative allosteric
modulator, now this is
going to be an inhibitor,
is going to bind to
the allosteric site,
the neighboring site
near the active site
and cause a conformational
change in the
active site such that
the affinity is reduced
for the agonist and
the efficacy for the
agonist is reduced.
And here we have this,
this is control, the
usual Emax right here.
And with the reduction
in the affinity
for the site,
depending on how much
allosteric modulator
is there and whether
or not it's reversible,
it will cause a
decrease in the
effect of the agonist.
so that is the classic
receptor theory up
till now we've been
talking about antagonism
by drugs at the
same receptor as the
drug of interest receptor
mediated antagonism
These other mechanisms
are different.
They are not receptor
-mediated. The
antagonist drug will
act at a totally
different receptor,
possibly even
a totally different
organ system.
So a physiologic
antagonist, called
often a functional
antagonist, is a
substance that
produces physiologic
effects that
are opposite the
physiologic effects
of another substance.
In other words,
their functions are
different. They act on
different regulatory
pathways mediated by
different receptors.
Typical examples
are insulin,
which reduces
blood sugar, and
glucagon, that
increases blood sugar.
Methacholine, which
is a drug that
causes
bronchoconstriction, while
albuterol causes
bronchodilation.
Opposite effects.
A chemical antagonist
is a compound
that directly interacts
with the agonist,
such that the
agonist is no longer
able to travel to and
bind its receptor.
The combination product
is inactive and excreted.
Examples here are heparin
bound by protamine,
divalent cations
and antacids
that chelate
certain drugs,
tetracycline being
a typical example,
Cholestyramine,
that is an exchange
resin that
sequesters drugs.
Cholestyramine
is not absorbed,
therefore the drugs
are not absorbed.
And I will elaborate on
these mechanisms here.
Insulin is secreted from
the endocrine pancreas.
It acts on insulin
receptors on
various cells,
certain cells.
and causes glucose
uptake storage
and therefore
removes glucose from
the blood sugar,
lowering blood sugar.
Glucagon also
comes from the
endocrine
pancreas, different
cells, and it
acts at the liver,
causing gluconeogenesis,
synthesis of
glucose, which then
increases blood sugar.
This concept has a
clinical application
because insulin
and glucon are both
available in drug
form. They can be
injected. So for
an individual, a
diabetic, who has
hypoglycemia, this is
a serious adverse
effect of insulin,
glucagon can be
administered to
increase the
synthesis of glucose
in the liver and
counteract the
hypoglycemia, raise
the blood sugar.
Inhaled methicoline
is a drug that's
given as something called
a bronchoprovocation
test for diagnosis
of asthma.
It will act on
muscarinic receptors
in, that's not
a very good M,
muscarinic receptors
in bronchial smooth
muscle and that will
cause contraction or
constriction. We see
that here. The airway is
very narrowed and that
reduces the amount
of air that can get
through the bronchus.
Albuterol must be
kept close at hand
when When
methacholine is being
administered,
albuterol is also
inhaled, and it is
a sympathomimetic.
It acts on beta
-2 adrenergic
receptors. These
are obviously
different types
of receptors.
That will cause bronchial
smooth muscle relaxation,
bronchial dilation,
opening of the airway.
opposite effects two
drugs acting in the
same tissues but on
different receptors
now the chemical
antagonists bind
directly combined
directly with the drug
the typical example
is heparin, which
is a negatively
charged molecule.
When it is given
an overdose, this
is going to be an
accidental problem,
protamine may be
administered to combine
with the heparin.
and protamine is
a protein that's
positively charged.
And then this
combined product
here is inactive,
the heparin is
inactive, and
it is excreted.
Tetracycline is
an antibiotic,
one, two, three,
four, four cycles,
hence the name
tetracycline.
It is chelated by
polyvalent metal
ions, such as are
found in antacids, in
the gut, and therefore
the absorption
is reduced,
significantly reduced.
Cholestyramine has
a similar idea.
Cholestyramine is
not absorbed. It
will sequester
the drug and carry
it out. The drug
is not absorbed.
So those are examples
of functional or
physiologic and
chemical antagonists.
So I'm inviting
you to pause the
video and answer
these questions.
What is the difference
between the two
-state receptor
occupancy model and
the classical receptor
occupancy model
explaining drug
receptor interactions?
And how are antagonists
classified and
what are the effects
on agonist efficacy?
Now would be a
good time to pause.
So you're back now,
and the answer to the
first question is,
the two-state receptor
occupancy model
posits that receptors
in the receptor pool
exist in an inactive
and an active
conformation in the
absence of ligand,
with the equilibrium
favoring the inactive
state. The drug binding
to the receptors
shifts the equilibrium
depending on the drug's
relative affinities
for the active and
inactive states.
And the second question.
The classical model
posits that receptors
in a receptor
pool are quiet,
quiescent, unless
activated by a ligand.
Agonists have affinity
for receptors and
activate the receptors
effector pathways.
Antagonists have
affinity for
receptors but do
not activate the
receptors and they
prevent the agonist
from activating
the receptors.
Competitive
antagonists compete for
the same binding
site as the agonist
and affect the
amount of agonist
needed to achieve
a maximal response.
Non-competitive
antagonists reduce the
magnitude of the maximal
response that can be
achieved by any amount
of agonist without having
an effect on the binding
of the agonist to
the receptor. This is
because the noncompetitive
antagonists either
irreversibly occupy
the active site or more
commonly bind to an
allosteric site, a
site nearby, changing
the shape of the active
site, the confirmation
of the active site,
reducing the affinity
of the receptor for the
drug and vice versa.
Receptor dynamics now.
Everything in
our bodies is
dynamic,
changing, moving,
reaching equilibrium,
falling out of
equilibrium.
And receptor
dynamics is a
cellular regulation
that allows our
bodies to stay
in homeostasis.
Cellular regulation
of drug receptor
interactions prevents
overstimulation that
can harm the cell or
the entire organism.
As a result of
the physiologic
regulation,
many drugs show
diminishing
effects over time.
So we have some
terms here.
A diminished response,
frequently called
tolerance, due to
exposure to an agonist.
Receptor desensitization
is a decrease
in the coupling
efficiency of receptors.
The receptor and
the cell become
unresponsive or
insensitive to the
action of the drug
even in the continued
presence of the
drug. And I will
illustrate this
on the next slide.
Receptor downregulation
is just a decrease
in the number of
receptors which occurs
by internalizing, the
cell internalizing
the receptor drug
complex, and we'll
talk about that on
the next slide too.
When the rate of
receptor degradation
is faster than new
receptor synthesis,
fewer receptors
are present on
the cell surface
and responsiveness
to the agonist
is diminished.
Tachyphylaxis is
an acute, sudden
decrease in response
after continuous or
repeated administration
of the drug.
Now receptor
resensitization occurs
when the agonist is
withdrawn, in other
words the drug
is stopped, cells
recover full responsiveness
to a subsequent
addition of the
agonist, which I
will show you on
the next slide also.
Now there is something
called increased
sensitivity,
supersensitivity.
And this occurs in
the presence of an
antagonist where
there is insertion of
an increased number
of receptors because
of the presence
of the antagonist.
And that can make
the cells more
sensitive to an
agonist. And I'll get to
that, an illustration
of that as well.
Okay, we have panel
A and panel B. Panel
A is on top, panel
B is underneath it.
Panel A you can
see is a curve.
And this is an
example of the beta
receptor that I
referred to before,
which is called
a beta adrenergic
receptor or an
adrenoccepter.
So you can imagine
we're talking
about the beta
receptors on cardiac
tissue. We could
be talking about
beta receptors
in the bronchi.
We could be talking
about other types of
G protein coupled
receptors. measures.
We see that a dose
is given here, full
response, okay,
that's what we expect.
Over time, the effect
diminishes, even
though the same
amount of drug is
being given, to the
point where there's
really a very low
effect. effect.
So this could be
desensitization that's
occurring, downregulation
that's occurring,
and if it happens
fairly rapidly,
we call that
tachyphylaxis.
Now, the drug is stopped.
No drug.
Certain time frame,
whatever it is,
and the drug is
restarted at the
same dose dose, and
achieves the same
maximal effect
after that pause.
But of course tachyphylaxis
happens again.
And we think about that
very frequently with
opioids for example,
opiates, where they
achieve a certain degree
of efficacy initially
and then over time
the patient tends to
become tolerant to
that particular dose,
requiring a larger dose
to get the same effect.
Now let's look at the
mechanism here
on panel B.
Here we have our
agonist drug binding to
the receptor, and
if you count up all
these pass-throughs,
the membrane, you can
see it's the G protein
coupled receptor.
And the agonist
is here and it
activates this
downstream effect.
And at some point
inside the cell it gets
phosphorylated and beta
-arrestins bind here.
And that desensitizes
the receptor. It
will not be able
to respond anymore.
That's the theory
of how it works.
Then this receptor
moves on down here.
Let's say this
is a receptor
and it is being
endocytosed.
And here we have it
down here. You can
see the drug drug and
the receptor are in
the endosome. Now
this can go two ways.
It can be reintroduced
back to the plasma
membrane, drug
binds, we get the
full efficacy again.
Or it can be
degraded in the
lysosome. And when
this happens,
this is called
downregulation, new
receptors need to
be formed and that
can take time.
So that is a
description of receptor
desensitization
downregulation and the effect
is returned after
the drug is withdrawn
for a certain amount
of time, but then
the patient can develop
tolerance again.
So that's receptor
downregulation
with exposure
to an agonist
internalization
and degradation.
Now, receptor
upregulation can occur
in the presence
of an antagonist.
So an antagonist now
binds to the receptors
and we have here
an example, you see
this is an antagonist
here and all these
receptors are bound by
the antagonist and the
agonist cannot
activate the receptors.
Now of course, there
are going to be more
than three receptors
on a membrane and there
will be certainly
way, way, way more,
tens of thousands
more, maybe hundreds of
thousands more agonist
molecules in there.
But this simple
example really
serves to demonstrate
the concept.
So the cell responds.
The cell recognizes
that its receptors
are nonfunctional
and it responds
by inserting more
receptors on the
surface and here we have
the agonist binding
to the receptor.
Now let's say the drug is
withdrawn at this point,
we have, let's say
there's another receptor
here, we have twice
as many receptors
on the plasma membrane
compared to normally.
The drug is withdrawn.
All this drug goes away.
Now the agonist
comes out and it can
bind six receptors
instead of three
receptors. So the
response is going to
be much exaggerated
compared to normal
once the antagonist
is withdrawn.
So this membrane now
is super sensitive.
Now let's say we
have an example
again of our beta
blocker blocking
our beta receptors
receptors,
and more receptors
have been deposited
on the cell
membrane because we
have that antagonist
present. Now the
beta blocker is
abruptly withdrawn.
The patient's
been taking it for
a long time,
body got used to
the beta receptor
being there,
and all of a sudden,
in a matter of hours,
all of those receptors
are freed up.
And what's going to
bind to those receptors?
norepinephrine and
epinephrine, and what
can happen? The
supersensitive response, the
hyper-response increase
in blood pressure,
the patient can get a
hypertensive problem.
Again I invite you to
pause the computer.
How does receptor
desensitization and
downregulation
affect response to a
natural or drug
agonist? And, how does
receptor
supersensitivity affect
response to a natural
or drug agonist?
Please pause if you wish.
Well, you're back now,
so the answer to the
first question is
desensitization and down
regulation cause a
diminished response to
continuous or repeated
exposure to an agonist
that can lead to
fewer receptors or
desensitized receptors on
the cell surface. After
withdrawal of the drug,
cells recover full
responsiveness to a
subsequent addition of
the agonist. They
undergo resensitization.
Now supersensitivity,
continuous or repeated
exposure to an
antagonist can cause
upregulation of receptors
and insertion of an
increased number of
receptors on cell surfaces.
After the antagonist
is withdrawn, the
increased receptor
density can result
in an exaggerated
response to a natural
or drug agonist,
supersensitivity.
And our final topic,
pharmacodynamic
variability in
a population.
The response to a
drug, the effect,
is specified to
be either present
or absent in a
given individual.
It's an either
or event, which
is called a
quantal event.
Determining the dose
of a drug required to
produce a specified
effect, it has to be
specified in advance,
in a large number of
individual patients,
as in a clinical
trial, or experimental
animal and plotting the
quantal dose response
can be used to
generate some information
on the margin of
safety to be expected
for a particular drug.
To be expected,
remembering that each
individual is an
individual. And there can be
individual differences
between patients.
So we have our
figure here
on the right hand side.
And we have our
bell curve here.
cumulative curve here.
Now, each of these
individuals is given
a dose of a drug
and then observed to
see if the pre-specified
response occurs.
So we talk about,
let's say, sedation.
So the response
we're looking for
is sedation. And
at this low dose,
a few individuals have
exhibited sedation.
And at this dose, a
few more individuals.
And at this
dose, 50% of the
individuals have
exhibited sedation.
And on, and at this dose,
finally, all of the
individuals have
exhibited sedation. Now
look at this spread.
Some individuals
were sedated here,
half the individuals were
sedated at this
point, the ED50,
the dose at which 50% of
the individuals
responded,
and some of the
individuals did not
respond at all until
this high dose.
Now, thinking about
an even higher dose
that's given, we're
talking about toxicity now.
Whatever that endpoint
toxicity is with
animal studies, it
might be death, for
example. In clinical
trials, trials, it might
be the appearance of
a particular toxicity.
So if it's death,
this is lethal dose at
which 50% of the
individuals had died.
And if we're
talking about a
clinical trial,
for example,
it would be toxic
dose, 50, the point
at which 50% of
the individuals
demonstrated the pre
-specified toxicity.
Here a few of
the individuals
experienced the toxicity.
Here, 50% of the
individuals, or I should
say death, that's what
we're talking about
here, LD50, of the
individuals had died
at this concentration.
And at this
concentration, all of
the individuals had died.
So you can see there's
a big spread in
the concentration
that produced the pre
-specified effect in
different individuals.
Now what do we, how can
we use this information?
Well the therapeutic
index is an
estimate of the safety
of a drug, and I
have another figure
to show you this.
The median effective
dose, the ED50, is
the dose of a drug
required to produce
a specified effect
in 50% of the
population. So, these
are repeated concepts.
Median lethal
dose, the LD50,
is the dose of
a drug that is
lethal in 50% of
the population.
Median toxic dose,
the TD50, is the dose
of a drug that
produces a specified
toxic effect in 50%
of the population. it.
The therapeutic index
relates the dose of
the drug required to
produce the specified
effect to the dose
that produces the
undesired effect. So
it's a relationship
between the the benefit
and the unbenefit,
the undesired effect.
LD50 or TD50 are
experimentally defined
by the following.
Therapeutic index
equals the LD50 divided
by the ED50 or the
toxic dose 50 divided
by the ED50. Same
concept. A large
therapeutic index
indicates a wide margin. So
if the LD50 is here,
and the ED50 is here,
we have this margin
of safety in here.
Now, a small
therapeutic index, say
the LD50 is here,
and the ED50 is here,
compared Compared to
that other one, we
see we only have a
narrow range of safety.
And this range of
safety is referred
to as the
therapeutic window.
Looking at our
cumulative curves
again, here's our
ED50, 50% of the
individuals have
already already achieved
that desired
beneficial effect.
The rest of them
will achieve it
somewhere in this
therapeutic window,
but a few of them
will actually
be above the
therapeutic window,
and we see that this
is actually a dose
for some that's in
the toxic range.
Here, some individuals
will have already
experienced the toxic
effect or even died
even though the
concentrations in the
therapeutic window. Some
individuals are just
more sensitive relative
to the drug effect.
The therapeutic window
represents the range
of steady state
concentrations at which
the likelihood of
efficacy is high and
the probability of
adverse effects is low.
So it's just a
starting point.
This range does not
guarantee safety
or efficacy in
individual patients.
And in fact,
it wasn't even
efficacious in
these patients.
What is the clinical
value of the
therapeutic index and
the therapeutic window?
I think you can
answer this even
without pausing your
computer. But you, if
you wish to, certainly
think about it.
The therapeutic
index relates the
dose of a drug
required to produce
a desired effect
to the dose
that produces an
undesired effect.
It is an estimate,
estimate.
The therapeutic
window is the dose
range of a drug that
provides safe and
effective therapy
with minimal adverse
effects. It does
not guarantee safety
or efficacy in the
individual patient.
Optimize therapy for
the individual patient.
So how do you do
this? You have
to take a very good,
careful history
and that will
help guide you.
So in summary,
we have our
pharmacodynamics
is the study of the
effects on the
biologic systems.
We have our two-state
receptor occupancy
model that postulates
that receptors
in the receptor pool
exist in equilibrium
in two interchangeable
conformational
states in the
absence of a ligand.
Remember this is one
type of receptor.
The active
conformation and
the inactive
conformation.
Full agonists,
partial agonists,
neutral antagonists,
and inverse
agonists are explained
by this model.
Many drugs actually
do represent
this model, but
many drugs do not.
The classical receptor
occupancy model
postulates that
receptors are quiescent,
quiet, unless
activated by a ligand.
Agonists occupy
receptors, activate
their regulatory
effector mechanisms,
and produce a
response. Agonists
have affinity and
intrinsic activity.
Antagonists occupy
receptors, but do not
activate them, they
have affinity, zero
intrinsic allergic
activity and prevent the
agonist from occupying
the site of action.
Receptor antagonists
are classified as
competitive and
noncompetitive antagonists,
irreversible, and
allosteric modulators.
Positive allosteric
modulators increase
agonist affinity or
magnitude of effect.
But negative allosteric
modulators reduce
affinity and or
efficacy of the agonist.
Physiologic or
functional antagonism
results from
counterbalancing effects
on physiologic
regulatory pathways
by substances
acting at different
receptors or by
different mechanisms.
Chemical antagonists
sequester the agonist,
preventing it from
binding its receptors.
Cellular regulation
of drug receptor
interactions
can alter the
response to the
agonist over time.
Diminished
responsiveness, which is
tolerance,
tachyphylaxis, due to
continuous or repeated
repeated exposure
to an agonist
results in receptor
desensitization
and downregulation.
After withdrawal
of the agonist, the
cells recover full
responsiveness
to a subsequent
addition of agonist,
and this is called
resensitization.
An increased
density of membrane
receptors can result
from continuous
or repeated exposure
to an antagonist
after the antagonist
is withdrawn.
Activation by
the agonist can
cause an exaggerated
response.
Individuals in a
population vary in their
response to the same
concentration of a
single drug or similar
drugs, and a given
individual may not
always respond in the
same way to the same
drug concentration.
Quantal dose response
curves describes
the cumulative frequency
distributions of
responders defined
as an all or none
effect plotted against
the log dose of a
drug. The percentage
of the population
affected increases as
the dose is raised.
The parameters for
calculating the therapeutic
index are the dose
of drug required
to produce an effect in
50% of the population,
ED50, and the
dose that produces
death or toxicity in
50% of the population.
The therapeutic
index is an
estimate, that's
all it is, an
estimate of the
drug's safety.
The therapeutic
window is a range of
steady state
concentrations at which the
likelihood hood of
efficacy is high and the
probability of adverse
effects is low.
And that concludes
this lecture,
the series on
pharmacodynamics.